[Música]
de un amigo que tiene el poder de la
palabra
él cuenta historias de pondremos
pequeños
yo tenía unos ocho años
instruida de nuestro pueblo
se dejó la puerta abierta y aprovechamos
ya sabéis cómo somos los niños sobre
todo cuando somos pequeñitos
que con ese interés de saber que habrá
en la casa destruida que habrá en la
casa del mago
entramos y empezamos a trastear aquella
sala llena de marmitas humeantes y yo
era como veis en la foto todavía era
pequeñito y me digo que siempre estuvo
ahí para mí para narrar me mi vida me
cogió de un pie meses subió así que ves
que hay dentro de la marmita cada uno
era cómoda de obélix que era la marmita
de la fuerza porque no se ocurrió está
vivo aquí hoy día han lanzado durante
dedicaría a otras cosas
aquella era la marmita del optimismo ahí
va pegado el optimismo a mi identidad y
número puede arrancar no se lo puedo
sacar pero hay algo que he descubierto o
sea que el optimismo es una fuerza
política de primer orden es
transformadora te posibilita una forma
que te habilita para conectar con la
edad es una herramienta de intervención
social
y es con esta con esa herramienta que no
me queda otro remedio que ir por la por
la vida claro pero que hace un optimista
en este mundo que nos ha tocado vivir
este mundo que está lleno de dolor que a
veces es difícil creer que la vida pueda
tener sentidos rodeados y rodeadas de
tanta desigualdad según datos de
naciones unidas en el año 2017 87 mil
mujeres fueron asesinadas en el mundo de
esas 87 mil mujeres el 60% fueron
asesinadas en sus casas por sus parejas
ex parejas o familiares lo que es lo
mismo hay 137 hombres que todos y cada
uno de los días del año
asesinan a una mujer normalmente que una
mujer con la que comparten o han
compartido la vida en españa se estima
que son 600.000 mujeres las que son
victimizadas todos los años por sus
parejas
o exparejas en este año que estamos
llegando casi a los 50 hombres que han
asesinado a sus parejas o exparejas pero
también a 32 niñas y 1
y un niño si tenemos un panorama es
bueno en esto como conectamos con el
optimismo como puede
como puede cuadrar una estrategia
optimista para que puede servirnos ante
ante tanto dolor y ante y ante tanto el
sufrimiento y yo creo que el optimismo
debe ser informado ya tenemos que saber
qué es lo que está ocurriendo en el en
el mundo
pero los optimistas tenemos el pero y él
y si no cuando no cuando describimos la
realidad una forma tan dolorosa los
optimistas empezamos a preguntar y si
pensamos en los fallos del sistema si
nos centramos en cómo se han reproducido
hombres que han sido pacíficos hombres
que han sido cuidadores hombres que han
renunciado a la violencia y si
aprendemos de estos procesos de
socialización que no donde el modelo de
asturias hegemónico no ha sido exitoso y
si los podemos clonar desde aquí yo creo
que las 70.000 mujeres y hombres que nos
manifestamos en vitoria pero es que en
todas las calles de
de nuestro país ver todas las calles del
mundo hubo un grito un basta ya hubo un
momento simbólico que nos hace pensar
que tal vez sea real que estemos en la
era del feminismo que a pesar de todo el
camino que nos queda por recorrer esta
marea de mujeres con una agenda clara y
con una reivindicación dirigida al mundo
trasladan aquello que empezó a ocurrir
hace dos siglos cuando olimpia de woods
fue fue asesinada también por
reivindicar los derechos de las mujeres
es decir para mí para los hombres yo
creo que el feminismo tiene que estar
conectado con la posibilidad de que
nosotros también nos emancipamos y
conectamos el conectemos con una
humanidad
plena y re mismo conecta con la alegría
de vivir con la mirada crítica con la
capacidad de mirarnos al espejo e
iniciar caminos de transformación
aprender de vuestra experiencia llevar
el fantaseo con esa idea de aquellas
grandes mujeres que fueron nuestras
abuelas nuestras bisabuelas imaginad que
hubieran sentido ya que hubieran pensado
si revela que podido acompañar en las
manifestaciones del 8 de marzo
entonces yo quiero hacer un acto
psicomágico hoy aquí y quiero aprovechar
para poner en valor esa idea y esa
experiencia que a mí es una de las que
más me ancla en la vida
reconocer la memoria de nuestras
ancestras reconocer a aquellas grandes
mujeres quiero aprovechar para
presentaros a mi abuela paterna
valentina fernández seis hijos viuda en
1943 luego tuvo otros cuatro más y otros
dos que venían con la siguiente pareja
mi abuela materna
antonia gonzález ciudad su marido fue
fusilado cuando tenía 21 años en el año
39 que a veces pienso en aquella vida
tan tan tan dura tan terrible que
acompañó a estas grandes mujeres y aquí
tenéis a mi hija naia que juega fútbol
quiere ser presidenta alcaldesa jefa de
bomberas y escritoras además todo por
ese orden no me queráis qué fantástico
voy a hacer que pudieran dialogar aunque
sea por un segundo algo que tal vez
ellas ni siquiera pudieron llegar a
imaginar que sería que sería posible
pero claro en todo esto donde estamos
los hombres o sea qué pasa con los
hombres y cuando pensamos la
masculinidad en la era del feminismo qué
significa
cómo nos sentimos qué está pasando e
inevitablemente tenemos que pensar en
dios
imaginaos que hemos tenido que pasar de
dioses viviendo rodeados de privilegios
para convertirnos en simples mortales
que tenemos que negociar nuestra
humanidad con esa otra mitad de las
otras pero fijaros en ese gesto dios
estaba dando la vida a adam y donde
estaba tan tranquilo no decir bueno dios
ven aquí dame la vida que tú y yo somos
iguales
ese pacto entre iguales que también nos
ha explicado es el ya celia amorós pero
claro que está ocurriendo con los
hombres presuntamente al mente sentimos
desconcierto en lo más profundo miedo y
es en ese bendito miedo que a muchos
hombres nos está sirviendo para marcar
una agenda de transformación para decir
vale quizás no es justa la vida que
hemos que hemos vivido tenemos que
relacionarnos de otra manera vamos a
cambiar aprendamos de ese proceso de
transformación fantástico y exitoso que
habéis liderado las mujeres lo que está
ocurriendo con otros hombres que están
volviendo a la caverna donde están
volviendo te están saliendo otros se
están organizando en opciones políticas
y están estructurando pues un mundo
a ver que como suenan estos nombres
puesto nature and salvini viktor orbán
vladimir putin serrano y podríamos y
podríamos seguir y fundamentalmente
tengo una noticia buena y otra no tan
buena como dice michael cashman la
violencia contra las mujeres no es un
problema de las mujeres que es un
problema que tenemos los hombres pero
que sufren las mujeres luego como parte
del problema también podemos pasar a ser
parte de la solución y la buena noticia
es que los hombres necesitamos la
igualdad y el feminismo y la mala
noticia es que para conseguir una
realidad una transformación real
de nuestra de nuestra sociedad de
nuestra realidad conseguir una igualdad
efectiva de hombres y mujeres pasa por
el cambio los hombres que se salió como
se hacen hoy os voy a contar la historia
de mi amigo el bombero para ver qué
cosas estamos que están pasando por
dentro de los hombres me invitaron hace
unos años a hacer una formación con 400
bomberos en bilbao pero los asustéis no
eran todos a la vez ni siquiera estaban
los del calendario sino eran de 2020
cuando estamos en la sala realmente
escuché unos pasos pones unos pasos
firmes en unos pasos que se hayan se
hacían notar y viene un bombero fue una
imagen épica porque era un ser humano
que mediría un 85 y con el traje
ignífugo y la y la máscara y las y las
botas los mediría dos metros él se sentó
cerró las las las piernas perros brazos
se me quedó mirando después una metáfora
en realidad preciosa de que está pasando
con los hombres es decir siguió un traje
puesto para un curso tan inocente como
formaciones género y más comunidades
para para hombres para bomberos que no
puede pasar ni el fuego que está viendo
pasan unidas
cómo vamos a llegar realmente a
establecer una comunicación pues fue
fantástico porque es esa metáfora
escondía el miedo que sentimos muchos
hombres hacia cantante ante el cambio
sabéis cómo terminó este este hombre la
última sesión me ayudó a recoger el
ordenador
se aseguró de que no había nadie
alrededor dice te puedo dar un abrazo
para decir como dice bell fuks todos los
seres humanos necesitamos amar y ser
amados y los hombres también no es bueno
y qué podemos hacer con los hombres para
que hagan un tránsito por esta
fantástica vía del feminismo y la
igualdad qué tecla podemos activar para
destruir el matrix para que realmente
nos demos cuenta que estamos estamos
desnudos yo creo que es algo muy muy
fácil de cuidar tenemos que cuidar tanto
como nos han cuidado tenemos que
identificar nuestros privilegios y sobre
todo ser capaces de renunciar a ellos y
sobre todo por encima de todo al uso de
la registración de la violencia y sobre
todo practicar la igualdad los 365 días
del año no si vosotros habéis podido
hacerlo nosotros también visualmente de
terminar con una idea hay muchísima
esperanza en el proceso de
empoderamiento que habéis vivido
vosotras y que están absorbiendo e
imitando nuestras nuestras hijas pero
por favor acompañemos también y no
abandonemos a los niños porque también
necesitan la igualdad y el feminismo
eskerrik asko
[Aplausos]